so you
can perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys welcome back to the
dope as usual podcast i am thomas
dobazillo whatever you want to call me i
am here with marty o'neil what's up
folks
weird week let's start this off let's
start this off right let me start it off
by telling you the truth the reading
rainbow theme song is slooping in my
head so bad i forgot to when you stopped
the music went
hey what's up guys so that's why there
was a slight pause because reading
rainbow is looping it won't get i don't
know why it's 25 years later but it's
okay lavar
should get his ass on here levar burton
that's his name just popped it in my
head yeah i don't know his name i just
know he's the reading rainbow star trek
guy uh-huh he's cool he's cool but it's
it's looping oh yeah so here we are this
is the dopey usual podcast we're here to
talk about life problems drugs
accomplishments and everything in
between
right now if you are watching this
episode if you have any time do us a
huge favor
right below the video there's a thumbs
up and a thumbs down
be awesome click the thumbs up button it
really helps youtube
they've been leaving us alone lately all
right they've been letting us breathe
letting us cuss and do stuff like adults
so thank you youtube for that but help
us out guys leave a like more than that
leave a comment let us know who do you
want to see on this show we get comments
we get suggestions all the time and we
take them into consideration as you can
tell big [ __ ] time yeah for real so
let's uh let's hop right into this
into some people you've asked for if you
have not been here for the past month a
couple weeks ago we had the eric khan
episode number two
all right the first time he came here he
was here for eight days he had just
moved here this time he had been here
for nine months or eight months
pretty cool i like having people back
like so how do you like l.a it was cool
eric's really nice dude the next guest
we had is a fan favorite probably my
favorite person to interview because
it's just ridiculous so [ __ ]
ridiculous me and april just watched it
back and we were just like
just laughing the whole time oh gee is
such a fool last night he faced taimi
at nine o'clock
and he opened the phone playing video
games joining his mouth no sure hey
so why'd you call me fool he's like i'm
in a match
call me after i waited for about five
minutes
i'm done looking at an up version of
your shirtless body danny trejo you had
a test dude so oh she's completely
covered in touch
somebody takes a shirt off
he was just trying to help you make your
own point
yeah i'm like dude just answer after
anyway
og episode was great he's a fool and he
still hasn't watched it he still won't
he's still too scared he won't do it he
just hates seeing himself on camera but
i think it's funny like his episodes
almost got a million views and he's not
looking at him
it's okay um the next guest is a fan
favorite the biggest suggestion that one
of besides goblin and eric
it's josh yeah for real josh kesselman
the owner of raw we had him on um josh
my homemade known for like almost a
decade now he's a really
really cool guy we've talked for a long
time over this decade i learned a lot
about josh during that episode a lot
more than i knew
prior i knew what he was dabbling in i
didn't know
the background of it and i loved it it
was
probably one of the best episodes i
would say so especially according to
just the response from the fans you guys
supported that episode so crazy the
comments in the premiere and just it's
hard not to sharing i mean there was i i
went through all the comments there was
two people being jerks and it's like
you guys are really hurting if you're
being a dick to the nicest [ __ ] man
on the planet
josh seriously i mean when the camera
went off josh is just as nice dude on
and off
all right so let's just get through that
i always like to recap because these
solo episodes are getting scarce we have
a lot of guests and we have three new
guests lined up yes some good ones not
gonna even hint anymore i don't wanna
throw it off let's just say it's gonna
be dope so guys that is my first point i
just wanted to recap
on um
the last guess and this is what's going
on
let's get into this
episode this one i swear if you've been
here for a long time you've heard me say
it 51 times
it's gonna be an hour and a half today
okay you've said that every episode i
know yeah i know what a tricky week
though there's been there's a weird week
i have to be here
in like eight hours again
all day i was here it's this is hour 13
me here at the warehouse today and
yesterday was like a 15 hour day we're
building but i'll get into that later
guys let me get into my next topic
the franklin episode
sean fontino you guys watched it
franklin from gta episode we brought up
a mutual friend how i met franklin we
brought him up right
and in the episode franklin was like
yeah you know donnie he's kind of sick
right now but you know he's going to be
good
[ __ ] donnie passed away yesterday and
it's [ __ ] weird
it's so odd i woke up to the post to dj
pooh posting i'm like hey
i saw the caption like oh my [ __ ] god
dude
because you know when you see the
capture like i mean when you see the
picture like hey what's up donnie i
haven't seen
why is there somebody and i looked at
the caption i'm like
r.i.p oh my [ __ ] god
such a bummer man he was a
he was a young dude i'll show you the
picture he looks like a 30 year old man
but he was like 55.
that's just sad man donnie was such a
nice dude he's the guy we're talking
about that she told me like i'd play the
voices on grand theft auto man like yeah
rightful so um there was a story i
hinted at in the franklin episode and i
went you know what
for legal purposes let's just not tell
that story but donnie i hope you're okay
with me talking about this story
uh really that's it's such a bummer dude
it really it was just sad he was one of
the nicest people ever such a nice dude
but also don't [ __ ] with him one of
those guys like such a nice guy he looks
like me like andy milinakis disease he
looked like he was 29 years old but he's
almost 60 years he's 55 years old bro
donnie was cool so i'm gonna tell you
the story real quick just real quick all
right uh what time are we at right now
part eight
i think i'm gonna light it up
rip donnie anderson
so sad bro
i couldn't i couldn't believe i couldn't
believe that
so here we go here we go
so something to pick your spirits up let
me tell you about the funniest first
impression i ever [ __ ] had with a
person with any human this might be the
wildest [ __ ] i have ever like
you casual [ __ ] so donny used to
be snoop dogg's manager in the 90s
donny's a hood [ __ ] but donnie
also he was part of the naacp all right
he was on the board he's a
upstanding ass man that used to be with
it probably was still i didn't ask you
know that and that was the sound of
marty
popping open a pre-roll muted my mic
um
so that's why i told you that's why i
want to say that he used to be snoop's
manager when the death row [ __ ] was
happening so you know that
motherfucker's hard
but such a fun loving such a nice dude i
i really love that dude
um so first time i ever met him i met
him with dj poo another mutual friend
and it was donnie i walk in and i'm like
sit at the table who is this young ass
dude because i i was like 24 at the time
i look young right now i look like a
baby and i said damn who's this young
dude and then the light hit him and go
you're a grown man because he was like a
darker restaurant and then he started
talking like you
look like a kid man you're so lucky
you're gonna be like you lucky
[ __ ] you look so young how old
are you
anyway talking to him
such a nice [ __ ] dude this is pre
pre uh
be finding out about gta i didn't know
about gta yet so i'm like just chopping
it up he's talking we're cool
and it's a short story
okay
imagine me all right he's a very nice
like hey one of those guys
um
so we're all having lunch or dinner
whatever it was we're at like uh it's
before us have to eat meat [ __ ] we're at
a
like a
grill the one you cook your own meat on
the you know what time what you cook
with [ __ ] eric was talking about cook
your own meat you make your food so
we're all doing that
we're outside we're smoking a joint
we're just standing at like 15 minutes
we walk into the parking lot if you're
in l.a and you're in koreatown those
parking lots [ __ ] suck and you know
that
so
the parking lots are like
lines obviously like a parking lot but
there's patches so you can drive around
through these plazas if you've been to
koreatown you know what i'm saying so
donnie parked on one of the blocks one
of the little bricks of uh parking so
those cars cars cars we come out
and there is a car
parked so close and blocking donny's car
in i mean
what a rude [ __ ] to park like
that guys here's his car there's a trash
can dumpster's behind him so he can
drive out cars next to him cars next to
him man parks right and [ __ ] in front of
his car i mean
so [ __ ] up i went oh
you piece of [ __ ] and donnie just looked
at me like [ __ ] people man kind of
car was it it was like a regular honda
accord like a random regular white car
so
i'm with my mutual friend that
introduced me to donnie and rosie right
dj poo had left like five minutes after
smoke will join he was like i'm out me
and johnny were talking because he was
real cool so we're like yo man i'm like
what are you doing i'm telling him like
the [ __ ] we do
and um
my mutual friend and don you're like
this [ __ ] that's [ __ ] people
man me and rosie are just like
waiting for our uber because we hadn't
even lived here we're in l.a wait for
our uber to go back to our hotel
that's how long ago this was
i see donnie walk about 30 feet
looks at the car parked in front of
him like he's sizing it up
four wheels all right like he was like
contemplating
turns around looks at us nice to meet
y'all
and as he smile goes away
whips out a knife
starts popping all these [ __ ] fools
tires bye bye
now you can't leave values can't leave
puts it away goes
you guys be safe not like
oh i'm hard he just did it like
you saw me all right later guys and i
went that was the hardest thing i ever
saw in my [ __ ] life
that was the dopest [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my [ __ ] life
with a smile
gets in his car and wiggles his ass out
somehow got his [ __ ] car around the
trash i don't know how he did it
was he driving i can't remember but i
remember looking at it like that's a
nice car
he was really into hot rods and [ __ ] but
it wasn't a hot rod and uh
me and rosie are just
yo did you see this you see this nice
ass man spot not slash
gut he gutted this man
put it away
see you later yeah like uh like the
truman show i just thought about that
good afternoon good morning good
afternoon good evening good night
um
so me and rosie are just like what the
[ __ ] as this dude's backing out and our
uber pulls up by five minutes later and
as our uber pulls up i open the door to
get in i look up and there's this older
asian man like this
looking at his car
look at his tires like what
my tires are flat and then we just left
you know what you [ __ ] deserve that
one bro
you really deserve that one that's tough
but that was my introduction to donny
god damn very
very fun fun story just because
when i think about the smile uh-huh hey
truman that's a smile again
he's a big dude so it's like
he's just seeing him so
jolly
[ __ ] that
he really was his manager in the 90s huh
[ __ ]
the hook is hard um so that's my donnie
anderson story uh rest in peace of donny
really [ __ ] sad bro he died i think
yesterday
crazy weird
yeah we're just talking we're just
talking about a man i said man i need to
hit him i even told frank i'm like i
gotta hit him up i haven't seen him in a
long time
you gotta hit up your friends hit people
up that you haven't seen in a minute i
text my homie today one from oklahoma
and he literally goes what the [ __ ] i
was picking up my phone to call you
looked at my text i haven't talked him
since december
what a weird yeah i gotta do that more i
know i've got him got it dude i don't do
it enough
but yeah that's my
ah that's daddy
donnie story
wild
um that fool's lucky he was inside
he's very uh articulate he would have
been like sir can you please move your
car you're parked illegally
uh until he moves
but i just i just saw it at him like the
young like
[ __ ] this he was you could see
it wasn't like he's like don he's a
menace it was did you really almost park
on top of my car [ __ ] you i'm telling
you the way he was parked i would have
kicked the door extra i would have
kicked the [ __ ] panel no matter
i couldn't let that go
it's like they went
like [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever you got going on
yeah dude
[ __ ] you that's what happened so uh
we'll get on to the next topic um guys
i'm really really trying to keep an hour
and a half i'm i'm doing my best i think
this might be the only time we ever
15 minutes in
all right
on to my next little topic
you know what i'm gonna have to switch
up my notes a little bit all right marty
how far are you on your house
but this [ __ ] has been a long time in
the [ __ ] making and it is almost
[ __ ] finished you're in the 90
percentile all the major major things
are done for the most part
and it's just man everybody's been
watching me and kind of like supporting
me along with this like renovation and
buying the house been probably the
biggest goal of my life i've ever
had happen
and i really appreciate everybody's
support with it but i just want
everybody i want people to put that in
their minds as
what to do
because
i don't know i just feel complete in
life now like i feel like i have i don't
know it's just completely changed the
way i feel and it's just kind of really
changed the dynamic in my whole family
with my kids we have our own [ __ ]
[ __ ] now but it's a game changer because
you know now we have some ownership and
we can
have some options and you all hear this
but maybe up
a lot of money yeah but it's like it's
an ironic thing because man when you
renovate a house there's so much
unforeseen [ __ ]
and you just have to go all in on it
it's so [ __ ] expensive
and then it's like yeah the situation
we're in it's like you go all in on this
house and it's like yeah we got
we did it but now we're starting from
[ __ ] scratch oh i'm talking about how
you were like if we appraise this we can
yeah we could we're up now i mean that's
how that's why real estate's so valuable
because we bought this house
and we put you know a good amount of
money into it but just the way that the
market's changing right now
it's worth
a substantial amount more than what we
bought it for already
there's a lot of factors that go into it
but that feels good knowing that it's
like a big savings account it's
literally you have your house and then
the extra profit savings for just making
it better so yeah we'll see we'll see
depending on there's a bunch of
different factors like um
you know the different rates that come
with mortgages and they all fluctuate in
the [ __ ] war and all this crazy [ __ ]
going on your wife's a relative yeah she
knows all this otherwise i'd be a
[ __ ] lost guppy out here april's a
straight up [ __ ]
real eternal she knows how to do
everything i i was trying to buy how she
was wait till september yeah all right
i'm gonna listen to you but i would be
willing to like flip it in the sense
that if we're able to sell it and have a
profit to the point that we could get a
at least make a lateral move but then go
get an investment property too and have
a savings
that would be a really good as much as i
love the [ __ ] house and would stay
there forever like that'd be a good
parlay because we want to just
get deep into this real estate [ __ ] and
for everyone out there from small towns
or from [ __ ] towns like marty and i
it only takes some time some thinking
and effort
i mean it takes time obviously it took
10 years to get this [ __ ] so much
[ __ ] time also you're [ __ ] sitting
there
working your ass off all these comedians
doing all your things
probably not getting paid what you
should have been getting paid because
you're like no no i'm not going to ask
for a raise i need to keep this [ __ ]
and you're like kind of eggshelling
and now it's like no you're doing your
own [ __ ] [ __ ] it yeah exactly that's
exactly what happened that feels so
amazing the fact that this [ __ ] all
worked out is like
i haven't even really realized how
[ __ ] awesome the whole situation is
and how everything's happening just
because i'm so in the moment but it's
just it's [ __ ] crazy
there's a lot of like
really amazing [ __ ] going on there's a
lot of like you know turbulent [ __ ]
going on but it's i find that that's
what just how it goes like you can't
have the in without the yang and you got
to just keep pushing through
both the same way
you know what i mean and it's like when
these good things come
it's almost scary when you start
realizing the things that you've always
wanted but it's like [ __ ] that this is
me we gotta push through all this [ __ ]
it's malcolm in the middle you still
haven't watched malcolm everybody go
comment mart you can watch malcolm in
the middle you have malcolm in the
middle syndrome it can't happen you have
george costanza syndrome something good
can't happen god's gonna take it away
from me that's the scary part that's
exactly what they say yeah that's the
words george says like i can't be
successful god would never let that
happen
he's like no i'm gonna have cancer i
have cancer he's like i know i'm
successful like it's just yeah i know
it's like that when you grow up with
nothing i think it's what it is you're
like you know it could be taking it it's
gonna be gone and keep it going you
spend so long out of the present moment
in the space of nah this is me out there
doing this [ __ ] having this doing that
this is me that's me when i'm in that
position and you spend your whole life
not being you
but then when you get to that position
it's like oh my god whoa i can't [ __ ]
believe this [ __ ] is happening like this
think about it even though i just have
had so much belief this whole time
you're positive but also when it happens
you're like am i wrong yeah i mean am i
tripping is this going to last a week
yeah exactly but
anytime you tap into greatness [ __ ] that
you gotta just go any time you get to
tap into something special
you can't be afraid of anything
associated with it run with it split
screen you know what's thinking about
the other day mm-hmm you guys know all
right we used to do side angle side
angle remember the when we started doing
split screen mean the gas split screen
that was a [ __ ] accident yeah our
main camera overheated on the shovel
that was a tragedy i almost [ __ ] shot
myself oh my god we were [ __ ] dying
like we just lost the whole shovel
episode like no no side cameras well
let's try to make it work and we went
this is so
tight and we've kept it since episode 4.
it's very true you know it was a fluke
and we went now let's make something
positive out of this [ __ ] negative i
was going to throw the [ __ ] up in my
bathroom i remember i was sitting there
you taking it
would you ask him to come back no that
was can't fake that you can't re
uh duplicate
a [ __ ] interview that's why i always
feel bad for people when they tell me
they want to get into podcasting i'm
like oh sweetie you don't understand
what the [ __ ] you're getting you want to
punch yourself in the mouth twice a day
for the first year
going how the [ __ ] did this happen
why did this happen so much [ __ ] you
have no idea how many times marty have
you ever done something completely right
and go why isn't it working still and
you well you know then you call and they
go well this is odd i've never seen this
you know what i'm gonna put a file
customer reporting i've never seen and
it's like of course you've never seen my
[ __ ] yeah
many times
yeah many times so you know as soon as
marty started working with me i go don't
worry you're gonna get [ __ ] soon yeah
that's just what happens that's why i
love working with you every time
something happens you're like yep nope
that's right about right yeah it's gonna
happen oh you lost the whole thing yeah
sounds right
yeah dude
it will happen just smile and go
[ __ ] it dude people have been
i don't know what it is lately
sticking out another sorry people have
been so rude to me lately
i don't know like in public when i go to
like
places um i i even like look at like
remember when uh friday's like craig you
look high and he goes
i look i look hot straight that's how i
feel like am i am i rude why are you
looking at me like that dude i don't
know what it is lately
you know what let me just roll right
into my next topic here's a story time
oh [ __ ] oh man i gotta get bruce on the
[ __ ] board
i can't wait i can't wait
here's a story time
oh that's exactly how i feel it's one of
those
if you feel the frustration
just remember
i lived through it
all right ready guys
i have my brother
his friend
and my friend justin boyd all in town
for two weeks they left like two days
ago
i was gonna go buy some [ __ ] so i went
to the bank to take money out
like a normal human
i go guys wait in the car no you can
leave it on i'm just [ __ ] withdrawing
money i'll be right out i walk up to the
bank that's [ __ ]
it's always [ __ ] [ __ ] bank of america
i walk into bank of america the one by
my house it's always a line out the door
i walk in and go
not a single person in line
like [ __ ] yeah
i walk up and i see an old man try to
get in front of him like i open the door
for him but he's the atm like
it's paying off today i love today i
walk in like you know what i'm dressed
nice i'm about to go vlog
they're not going to give me no [ __ ]
even though i why should i worry about
that
you ready marty
i walk up and as soon as the lady called
him like you don't look very nice
i don't have a personal checking uh i
have a personal checking account but i
don't have the card with kovid i've been
asking and requesting one every [ __ ]
month they haven't sent it it's been
like nine months
i haven't got my cards i've been using
rosie's card
does not have my name on it it's the
worst it's the worst [ __ ] the only card
in my name that i have physically is my
push trees business card
cool same account but a business where
mine and rosie's names are on it cause
people have to get our name our social
security all this you know when you sign
up for a bank you have to give your
information
so you know how your name's on the
account
i walk on and said hello lady
i give her my
federal [ __ ] id of california give
her my id
and i go hey i need to withdraw money
but i only have my wife's garden
and um
she goes i'm sorry i can't do that but i
do it every time
she goes yeah what i was taking a lot of
money she's like over the certain amount
i can't do that i go
[ __ ] i'd say [ __ ] i went so what can i
do cause rosie's at the warehouse and
i'm like four miles away i'm like i am
not dragging rosie out here but you had
your license i had my [ __ ] license
with my name and pictures it was banks
before the debit card
marty gets worse
guys
i'm such a nice person i'm not going
gonna hit nobody i wanted to punch
through this lady's chest and rip that
like [ __ ] dumb and dumber
that's how i felt
i tell her
what if i transfer the money to my push
trees account i can do it right now can
i take the money out of my account since
my name's on that card of course
and first of all first off let's start
let's get back to the checking account
and i go
well i'm on the account so yeah i see
your name here but you don't have a car
to go
but i have an account and i go you know
what that's reasonable that's reasonable
she's like i can send you a code and you
have to show it through me for your
phone and then i can verify you that's
one way bank of america does it they
text you a code while you're in line
like yo look here's the code okay match
is mine verified that's what they do
i've updated my new number about five
times
not once have they made it stick in the
system
i tell her yeah send me the code she
says what's the number i tell the
numbers it's not on here i go
you haven't updated it i i've came in
here multiple times and updated it on
paper on the ipad what do you need me to
do and she says you're not on here and i
go and i say the old number she's like
well if you have the old number i gotta
say the whole thing she goes that's the
number i go that you guys have an update
it's my old number i've been trying to
get you to update it i've done it online
twice
and she goes yeah can't verify you if
your phone number doesn't match and i go
oh my god
i think what if i text it to my wife and
i just show you the code she goes it has
to be in person i'm like okay you're
being difficult but i understand it's a
lot of money
okay i said oh boom transferred to my
push trees account can we give me that
card i'm just gonna put this card in
let's go about my day right marty
i can't see your foresee what problem
would occur here
you know me
i'll blow the [ __ ] up if i have to
and i was just keeping i was keeping
calm i was uh i was dad from christmas
story
under my breath
but away because i know there's a little
speaker i'm like
um yeah no here's the code
i put my card in and she goes yeah your
name's not on the account like oh stop
what did you just tell me
i'm like you have my id right does it
match the push trees business card from
bank of america she goes yeah but your
name's not on the account i go how is
this
possible
what are you trying to say did marty do
you get it do you understand how that's
real she said your name's not in the
account yeah your card works yeah your
id matches but you're not on the account
that doesn't make sense because how did
you look me up then i swiped the card i
swiped the card it has me and rosie's
names yeah she goes well i see a rosie
as the primary account holder i go why
does that matter you got the pin going
everything just like a normal and i go i
just deposited a check here a couple
days ago she goes anybody can deposit
checks that's not true that thank you
that's what she said i went you can't
anymore but i did it with the red card
you guys let it happen she goes yeah
anybody can deposit a check don't know
what to tell you and she's like egging
me like
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you she was like 60 years old she
had no she's been alive long enough not
to act like a [ __ ]
anyway i'm still keeping my calm guys
and i tell him like um
i don't know what you're telling me
she's like well i have to verify your
phone number and then i can let you go
and i go you didn't update it and she
says then i can't give you any money
and i go i have my card my id my
password everything at the bank until i
can my money cause my phone's not on
there go
pretend my phone got turned off
can i have my money now i don't have a
bank i don't have a phone pretend i
don't have a phone
and i went you know how about this can
you go get your manager because you're
not helping me no don't stop i was like
please
say nothing else you're not helping me
can i please get your manager
and guys you know the bulletproof glass
goes up pretty high
i'm not in shape can't climb a tree i
looked up and went could i get my leg on
there hop this
i was looking at and then i was like wow
you're gonna go to jail
but also [ __ ] it the world star video
that would come of dopaziola hurtling a
[ __ ] bank teller
bulletproof to get my own [ __ ] money
and i remember i looked up went one two
three oh i'm too short for that one
i
100 legitimately considered it and went
uh you know what i'll go to jail plus i
can't even [ __ ] do it i looked at it
and looked at the steps like if i open
that door i can step on the top of the
door
and i was just looking at it uh i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
let's just leave it at that
considered spider manning and i was like
[ __ ] upset marty
meanwhile my car's on i'm at minute 27
in here
i text justin at minute 30 i'm like can
you turn the car off
gas is expensive and i'm idling in a
[ __ ] amg
i thought i was walking in and walking
out i didn't want it was hot i'm like i
don't want you guys to [ __ ] be hotly
there
so i'm a quarter tank deep pissed
watching this [ __ ] woman talk to this
other woman
eight feet from me and she's look
the manager walks over to me guys this
is where
so far marty i'm supposed to have my
money right
yeah bank card id pin number face uh-huh
she walks over to me she tells me the
same thing she's like your phone number
does not match we're not gonna give you
any money we can't go but i'm on the
account
it's just your phone number does not
match i don't care if you're on the
account like oh she just said i wasn't
now you're saying i am
and she went
i mean your phone number doesn't match
and i'm sitting there like and i looked
around and everybody else
and this time there's like five people
behind me now
there's seven tellers but there's a line
these people are so [ __ ] lazy they
just sit down with their window closed
and talking to each other that's why i
hate going to that bank and i want you
know what [ __ ] i just need money it's
gonna be a good day i'm vlogging let's
get it [ __ ] it and then
she tells me and i and i interrupt her
i'm like no but i just and she goes do
not interrupt me sir
and i went you don't interrupt me
i was like oh i just want my money you
have my money
and i go you know what i'm just going to
get my wife an uber here and she could
take it out because this is crazy why
can't i have my own money she goes
she is the primary holder right you just
said you're not the primary are you
trying to catch me in a lie it doesn't
matter if you're a primary thank you
that's why you have multiple people on
an account thank you and then
i started talking she goes stop
interrupting me sir
and i go i don't know what you want she
goes all right look it your wife can
come in i'm not giving her any money
you're not getting any money in this
account you're not getting any money
from any of your accounts in my bank get
out of my bank that's what she told me
marty she told me get out of my bank i
looked at her i mean what the [ __ ] did
you say she'll get out of my bank you're
not being helped here
no [ __ ] and until that point i wasn't
rude at all i was just
i was just doing this
with my hands on the thing like next to
the pen looking at her
and i was like give my [ __ ] card
and then say i gave you a card i go my
[ __ ] other one
she handed it to me
and i went
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i was the
only time like you [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
started walking and as i was walking i
called roses like you take all the money
out of every account of bank of america
i'm done
guys that's not over i was so frustrated
i was so frustrated and i'm not
exaggerating leaving anything out i mean
i felt insane i felt crazy like
it's ironic because i did the same me
and april have the same stupid [ __ ]
going on where we have one card and the
business card i did the same [ __ ] today
and had no problems
marty yeah
i tell rosie what's happening and by the
time i get to my car she's on phone
corporate
changing my numbers so this doesn't
happen and the guy i'm on the speaker
phone with the guy too because i picked
rosie up to take me to another bank
because obviously you're the [ __ ] cow
holder i gotta go pick so i had to go
all the way back get rosie
excuse me
on the phone with the guy and he goes
you had an id
i go sir i had an id my card my pin
number and my face and he says
are you sure you're telling me
everything that happened dude you're
just as [ __ ] confused as i am because
i don't know what to tell you
it's like i've never [ __ ] he like
i've never encountered this
i go yeah you know what he's like i'm
gonna file a report i'm gonna file you
know i'm gonna file more i'm gonna
follow multiple reports on her this is
ridiculous and i told him like
thanks went to the other bank and they
go you're supposed to call 24 hours
ahead if you need to take out that
amount of money
i'm gonna throw up and she goes you only
take out this amount of money go
can she take out some and i'll take out
some she goes yeah go yeah so i got that
amount that i needed
and left
wow
like a gentleman
i almost threw up from frustration jesus
christ marty i was so upset
i was so mad i had bank of america close
my account without telling me once when
i was [ __ ] broke they closed my
account and they said we'll mail you
your money and it took like three weeks
they mailed me my money and it was uh
300 overdraft fees when i was 18 years
old from bank of america on our on
olive
16th mm-hmm
yeah that happened to me when i was 18
they closed and you've been overdrafted
for a month like since [ __ ] i paid my
[ __ ] car payments you tell me and uh
they closed it on me too but they sent
me a bill they didn't send me
they didn't send me money yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] goddamn
buddy gets better okay what time are we
at right now
35. the story has a bright side
are you ready
i'm ready for it i don't know if you are
okay
it's it's miller time
von miller times
oh the new
new buffalo bills player von miller
let's [ __ ] go
you ready are you looking for a sound
bite so it's all right okay that's all
you just
are you ready
we started working together marty
20 20 20.
start the podcast february 8th
21
21
i told rosie
the night we got home you know how we
did the first episode and and then we
like yo let's let's do it again we
[ __ ] up a few things like yeah let's
run it all the way back [ __ ] it we did a
whole new topic knew everything so
episode one is really episode two
episode one is in the bank we have it
still we'll put that [ __ ] out we need
to huh the first unreleased episode ever
we have a unreleased episode guys
i think we might have two
i feel like we have two but i know for
sure that first one was we filmed
february 6th and we oh we [ __ ] up oh
we needed to fix this kind of a practice
it was practice but february 8th were
like we were filming the real one
that night i went home and i told rosie
rosie
this is going to be good i have a
feeling this is going to be a really
good show we're going to we're going to
crush this
and i told her because you know me bro i
barely started [ __ ] making any type
of money from doing anything that
four months before i met you marty the
first time i know eight months where i
met his first time ever got paid for we
chit ever and then you came at me with
that package and went
don't [ __ ] make it and i was like no
we're gonna make the money somehow
february 8th i went home and i went
rosie
we need to make this successful enough
there's a certain thing i want out in
one year's time i want to be able to
have enough money to not be stressed and
buy marty something there's a certain
thing i've been wanting to get you for
since
the night of the podcast i'm like
i can't wait do me a favor
reach under your desk what i told you
was trying oh [ __ ]
i'm really excited i have no idea what
the [ __ ] this is i know you touched it
earlier it's trench leave it
i want you to open that
that is for you thank you for everything
thank you for [ __ ] helping my life
get better
you're the man
oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] rolex yeah
yeah
i've been staring and looking for months
for months and it's my color for me
thank you thank you that's [ __ ]
i don't even know what to say i've never
had anything nice
i feel you i saw her go
he didn't wear [ __ ] like that but i
think he'll like it
wow
you're a [ __ ] g let me just tell if
anybody's wondering i mean even outside
of this
you showed me the picture i got to try
on jewelry one time for a photo shoot i
went you buy marty a [ __ ] rolex one
day watch oh my god [ __ ] it it finally
happened
that day when i saw her go
he does like jewelry that's the only
time i've ever worn jewelry
i knew it and us the only time i ever
had a nice watch and i go
the rolex is it then that was like six
months ago
[ __ ] put it on thank you man put it
on i gotta see it
the guy told me also yeah that whole
time getting the money out because i
want people buy that they were being
dicks to me dude and the watch guy was
like yo are you gonna be here i'm like
yeah i'll be there i'll be there i'll be
there and they just kept [ __ ] up and
like the banks kept [ __ ] up and
yeah
i really don't know how to put it on
it's a class or no you you it's like one
of the little
hooks
yeah yeah yeah and he says if it's too
big or too small we can change the links
damn
homie
this [ __ ]
fits [ __ ] yes i was really hoping it
would [ __ ] fit wow
i got it and he's like i just got it
from the showroom two days ago so in
there
in the card it's literally bought a [ __ ]
i've been sitting on this for a week
every time you're like can we do it
tomorrow i'm like oh
[ __ ] oh man yo so every time you're like
yo what about thursday i'm like uh yeah
that's fine i've been staring at it
going
come on i bought that [ __ ] a week and a
half ago just staring at every day like
when are we gonna do the [ __ ] next
solo episode guys i've been going
through so much [ __ ] this week i know
that's i'm like don't worry man you'll
feel better after the episode dude so
look you got a [ __ ] house
the [ __ ] car and now you have the the
businessman's watch
[ __ ] is crazy man
thank you man don't worry if it's it
works
matches you well it matches your hat
damn
it's the same thing when you walked in i
went
no i was like what's up [ __ ] where's
the blue hat
oh keep everything he said even the
stuff inside yeah because the the papers
go with it come on man yeah
crazy
i thought this was some of the trance
[ __ ] jerry curl juice down here
let's retouch and go oh [ __ ] it's
trance
wow yeah
[ __ ] yeah
it's been a little over a year i've been
i've been trying dude i've been tried i
was [ __ ] that's why i was vlogging
that day i told you
and then the uh the vlog the stop is
stash when i was in the jewelry store i
was trying to [ __ ] get you a rolex
that day and i went it's a secret
remember i was looking at that i was
trying to throw your ass off i was
trying to do it because i know you edit
our [ __ ] yeah so i was trying to throw
you off the trail like is he in a watch
door and i go i'm just getting a present
that's why i said that man
secret that's why i got the chain
instead i'm like
that's insane
sick though
no problem i'm [ __ ] stoked you're
stoked me and rosie i'm like yo
when are we gonna [ __ ] film and
my brother was with me everybody we all
we vlogged the whole [ __ ] thing i've
been filming this for [ __ ] a week and
a half little pieces when you were
pulling up i was filming a little bit
like all right
wow yeah
dude it's been so [ __ ] hard not to
say anything that's crazy i've been so
[ __ ] juicy i've never gotten like a
gift before like that well there it is
i remember before we started you go man
these [ __ ] out here buying
wraiths and rolexes and showman
[Laughter]
i don't i don't wear jewelry yeah you
don't say like i don't wear jewelry but
i don't know anything like when people
when people post some [ __ ] from like
you know 2012 and be like imagine if you
still dress like that like [ __ ] i don't
i do still dress like that i'm still the
[ __ ] same person
yeah except your jeans you're a little
more goodies and fitteds and [ __ ] like
man
that's i'm starting to feel a little bit
more like
starting to feel a little bit more grown
i got life insurance i got a house house
you got the new car
that's why i was like yo when you
brought the car i went
bro he is going to be so juiced
i got to put some panties in this here
it's not my mom's cup what do you say
get rich right no it's not my mama's
going to stop my mama's car he's got the
new watch on too that's why i was in man
like mark's going to be
thank you man no problem
i'm just happy
yes
[ __ ] yeah i've been waiting you don't
even have it you don't even have one no
i'm gonna run on rock jewelry bro
it's hard it's hard for me to i got to
watch on my uh graduation day my aunt
gave it to me i wore it graduation day
mm-hmm
i'm so animated i always go
[ __ ]
so when josh was checking out his rolex
and i already had the watch sitting in
my house yeah come on
when is this next solo episode
wow man
let's go
i was excited now
okay rosie was just all day like what
time is marty come like i don't know but
three guys are [ __ ] g's man you
really are like
i want to appreciate you brother we had
some probably i had one of the most
horrible things days ever yesterday and
i was just like i knew if i called you
i'd feel better and i did
yeah it's [ __ ] up some [ __ ] but
yeah work right through it yeah that's
why i told april i'm like it's nice to
have a real [ __ ] friend yeah someone
actually is [ __ ] like yo
what's going on i'm actually genuinely
happy for you yeah
yeah
yeah it's been a long [ __ ] time
well i appreciate you bro that's why i
had to do it day one february 8th 2021 i
remember we were sitting on the couch
went i'm gonna buy mario [ __ ] rolex
next to your watch we had ben grinding
at that point yeah we had already been
[ __ ]
going so hard dude
every day
mm-hmm [ __ ] it and i know it's not like
i knew you you don't wear wear [ __ ] like
that but i know it was like
that's a businessman's [ __ ] gentleman
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah you're a baller with
that [ __ ] it's not like my diamond ass
yeah it's like nipsy says it symbolizes
that men are present like oh there you
go
that's
[ __ ] know i'm out here making
moves and the other thing about it i
didn't know that [ __ ] is going to be
worth so much next year
um i don't know i have no
i didn't i don't even know the guy
explained it to me the value of rolex's
is the number one commodity in the past
eight years
to skyrocket in price
okay yeah i don't know anything about
that i didn't know just all i know is
camping's gonna be able to go to college
off of that [ __ ] if the [ __ ] keeps going
the way it's going it's [ __ ] insane i
didn't know that's why people invest in
jewelry it's a it's a it's a straight
investment i didn't know that
i thought it was the opposite of that
depends on what you get yeah couldn't
believe it bro
yeah but uh there was another one it was
story time orange but it was from a
trapper and i was like
i don't know if i trust that [ __ ] i
don't know i want to go to the chat
so i went to a legitimate [ __ ] spot
um
shout out to you i haven't been in the
vlog and [ __ ] shout out to brandon um
guys go back on my instagram if you want
to see a funny [ __ ] picture of the
one other time i ever wore a nice
jewelry it's way back there it's way the
[ __ ] back in 2000 and but
right with the watch
right we went up in brian michael's
jewelry this is
he go this dude is up on the top of the
g list with you
me and my homeboy walked in there no
money tried on all the [ __ ] and just
until we had our [ __ ] giant dicky
suits on all that [ __ ] and just said hey
we're putting out our music we want to
do a photo shoot in here he said say no
more go for it come back here you can
shut down half the store i like your
hustle wow
he had we had a literally a quarter mil
on each three of us no security this is
an older man he had us outside he
brought his old school bentley in
for us to take pictures in front of what
yeah the [ __ ] was ridiculous the [ __ ] we
had on was [ __ ]
stupid especially for the time i saw the
picture just like
bro you're gonna get shot yeah
[ __ ] were out there getting
shot in that [ __ ] too because i remember
when we walked in there the first time
my boy that i was with there was the
dudes pulled up in the benzes and [ __ ]
came out you can tell they're like dope
boys and [ __ ] and he's like these
[ __ ] keep getting robbed try to
tell him get insurance on that [ __ ]
can't can you i mean you can't get your
life back yeah dude that's sad jewelry's
sad my homie the one that steered me in
the right direction for that
um like just investment he bought his i
remember when he bought it like he was
so [ __ ] it was like 110 bands he
bought it he just sold he just made 275k
off his watch he's made a 275k off of it
[ __ ] out of here
didn't realize it was like that it's
like that it's just like that fools are
actually going up so if you have i got
uh my friend was telling me like dude if
you have 100 bands and in 10 years you
don't have 100 bands it's sitting there
but with inflation you have lost money
because why don't you put 100 bananas
and two watches put them in a safe when
you come out you have two pristine
watches now worth 70k over
like wow you [ __ ] smart [ __ ]
yeah i have a lot of trap it's weird i
have a lot of homies that are big time
travelers and they all recently gave it
up
like if i had five homies that moved
[ __ ] weight
two of them
two or three of them just stopped
they're like yo
i'm just tired of being on call
like since i was 14 i've been doing this
[ __ ] like i'm done
it's like dude you have enough money to
never work yeah just go chill
and then when i was like bro i'm gonna
start traveling i've never got to go
anywhere like i've been on the phone and
making [ __ ] moves for 20 years
it's crazy like i'm looking at i'm like
you're
you're gonna stop driving like bro i'm
just gonna hand it off to charlie and
chalk factory i'm just gonna hand it
down here's the connect here's the
[ __ ] routes damn kick me down some
money
but go kill it you're the next 20. do
you get into a groove where they're like
is no real risk or is the risk always
there there's always there
if you separate yourself at least two
degrees three degrees you're fine bro
unless that first and second third
degree go that shit's his
but
there's certain part there's
this is just weed
you're not going to prison for life for
some weed so it's not a huge deal
somebody can take a four-year sentence
making [ __ ] five million dollars
every three months like
where your sentence is okay
to some people i'm not going to jail for
any amount of money yeah no that's
that's [ __ ] nice about that get my
time back
the only reason i don't ever want to go
jail so i'm [ __ ] nice bro and i don't
want to [ __ ] people up
and i don't want to have to [ __ ] be
in that disgusting [ __ ] mindset of
like well get the [ __ ] away from me like
yo what's up what's your favorite movie
why you gotta be like that just based
off my like not being able to small talk
i'm gonna bash my head off one of these
goddamn bars
i remember like i tried to go to like
classes and [ __ ] after i graduated high
school did you learn small talk they'd
be like just
beyond not being able to small talk at
all like a normal human would i can't
sit in some [ __ ] period
though i remember the woman like this
has happened multiple times well they'll
stop what they're doing and be like do
you need to leave because you're like
hanging off the side of your desk like a
[ __ ] crackhead how do you know you
have how do you know if you have 80d
no it's not that i just i do to
everything i don't care about
oh yeah you know but in like a
debilitating kind of way
i feel like i'm gonna implode yeah in
school there'd be times i'm like
what do i do i can't 40 more minutes i'm
gonna [ __ ] throw up
yeah those times are depressing thinking
about having to sit and listen to a
[ __ ] and i got three hours of
sleep because i'm insomniac
it makes me feel sick
thinking about it all the time
oh god even just like
having the job like when i was really
when i just moved here and i was really
hustling the full-time day job plus all
this other [ __ ] i used to be so stressed
out every morning going into my job
because i'd get up at the ass cracker
dawn i'd get all my drastic graphic [ __ ]
going i'd get my school [ __ ] going and
then i have to go to my job and every
morning i'd have to stop my momentum i'd
be like i gotta go
do this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
but i mean he was my boy that i worked
for was great and he let me do my thing
but i just i remember that every day i
talked i was saying that to april
yesterday like mad remember when i used
to every morning be so [ __ ] stressed
that's what it's all about not having to
pretend like you care about some [ __ ]
you don't care about
that's tied to your income
thank god we get to pick our sponsors
because i would hate to go
pepsi
drink pepsi i mean hey i'm just saying i
don't [ __ ] with soda that's why i
couldn't promote so yeah don't [ __ ] with
soda we're all keep your deck clean keep
your dick clean
who are you gonna bet on
[ __ ] that i'm like yeah that's tight
or the the how we pick sponsors goes
our fans aren't going to want to see
that that's a lot of people that's the
first we turned out a lot of money from
people going
i'm not going to mesh sorry no point
not going to go hey here's an ad you
don't give a [ __ ] about
yeah or you'll never [ __ ] love
landscapes
there's a lot of dudes out here
there it is 94 there you go uh do you
drink beer
drink middle light uh-huh let's go i
mean it's it works fine do you not want
to be fat get some on it [ __ ]
i mean it goes it should flow it's
pretty [ __ ] easy it's like all three
three uh-huh you watch the super bowl
make a bad [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] bet five
bucks you want 180
come on
so yeah that's uh that's i'm happy for
that
dude i i totally get a waking up strat
for everyone out there that's on their
way to go get stressed
remember
you can always change where you're at
also if you can't change where you're at
you got to find something in your life
that you're stoked about because dude
i feel it there's been times where i'm
looking around when i was younger like
nothing is going to get me stoked i'm
broke as [ __ ] and how do i make money i
need money today not in two weeks
if i get a job today i can't get paid
for
a month i'm done where do i go what do i
do there's there was times like that i
was [ __ ]
and i'm not gonna sit here and ask
[ __ ] for money like my family
and [ __ ] so it's like i have to go get
it on my myself there's no way i can do
that
i mean i could they'll do it i just
i couldn't you know what i'm saying like
i smoke weed and i'm going to ask
[ __ ] for much i'm tripping yeah
i'm going to go stop smoking weed if i'm
asking for money first yeah also it was
when it was in the transition to stop
selling me when i stopped selling weed
to do the [ __ ] to do this basically and
i was so broke
it was horrible sometimes you got to go
all in and i know that yeah i mean the
universe likes that [ __ ] look what
happened 100
all in every day all day every day
every day and now i'm just trying to get
like what can you do let's start a
business what can you because i don't
want to like we said i try to get rich
and go hey you guys aren't making money
my friends
like [ __ ] that's one of the first things
that we said when we started this which
i really appreciated was i don't want to
be walking around here making a bunch of
money and you're not yeah for real like
that's not that's fun really good
leadership because that's how you build
a strong team why would you i've been a
part of a lot of teams and nobody really
takes that mentality and eventually you
end up cycling through 100 [ __ ]
people
because you're not [ __ ] appreciating
them yeah
what the [ __ ]
i don't know you yeah like why
marty
could you imagine
you know what i mean like if we were
making
shitload of i've been i've been there
before i don't know what the [ __ ] okay
you can imagine
yeah
okay i can't even give you the
comparison never mind hey thinking about
those times are over
basically what we're gonna say
so yeah for everyone out there having to
do that [ __ ] i mean we all worked
mcdonald's i worked at donald's i worked
a lot i want that for my 13 year old
more than anything because if i wasn't
obsessed with basketball if i didn't
have something that i was getting after
every day when i woke up
still to this day i don't know i'd be
probably [ __ ] super depressed yeah
looking at everybody else that you
follow on celebrities going well they're
doing this and this that's the number
one cause of depression is comparing
yourself to [ __ ]
hey
i'm not tall
well this [ __ ] looks just like
me that's tall why am i gonna go i wish
it was you cool
[ __ ] you
i don't give a [ __ ] you can't drive in a
porsche eat a date you can't even fit a
ferrari [ __ ] you
like
i feel like at least i don't know a lot
of people i feel like look at you can
look at the world and look at everybody
and just like the first thing you see is
like
what's better than you that's that's
what i'm saying what
you're looking at the
well what does he have better and and
everybody and everything that's what an
insecure person yes
stop doing that
please even when i was broke i never
went somebody else went oh i wish i had
that like
i don't wish i had that because that's
not the way i'm gonna do it that's not
how you get to what you want i remember
walking the streets from my job down in
downtown walking seeing all the cars you
know even impalas grand prix jeep
cherokees [ __ ] clean sick just like
not not talking about the 90s ones
though the long capri styles i'm talking
about some early 2000s yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then really like i don't know
if it's just coincidence a lot of the
cars i put on my vision board a lot of
the car like even the impalas the 300
c's they were like i really am sitting
here thinking about i'm writing lyrics
about these [ __ ] things and then
eventually it came to be
you know what i mean and then like like
i said we thought we were going in to
get another 300 c when we got the
[ __ ] bands sometimes things just work
out
yeah it's never come from a place of
like i need to have that
the the state of like
trying to attract something like damn i
deserve that i want that i know i can
get that that in the state of being like
hopeless like [ __ ]
i'm impressed
that's a very fine line in between those
two
you got to learn how to lean towards
that coach in your own head that
pats you on the back and tells you that
you can [ __ ] do it got it just give
it some time you got it that's what i
think about all the time my homie
charlie told me the other day is like
something they're making this much money
i go charlie i will be a billionaire by
the time i'm 40. and he goes
charlie there's no doubt in my mind
i'll be about 37 when i really pop the
[ __ ] off and make 100 mil in a [ __ ]
month i already know
and it's not about the money it's like
yo you know what [ __ ] i'm going to do
i'm going to build so many people
[ __ ] houses that's right
yeah josh he's on another thing josh is
a [ __ ] millionaire for the past 20
years
i'm trying you know what i mean i'm
trying to do this like
yeah the second i get [ __ ] money
i'm not trying to get millions and go
now i can spend it yeah yeah like i'm
trying to do it right now because
if it's gone yeah and if it's gone by
you that should hit me when you said
that cause you're true though if i went
broke today and everything sucked i'm
like and marty still got that [ __ ]
rolex apple's got that so he said when
you give it away you can never lose it i
[ __ ] get it i was thinking about that
earlier today i get it dude yeah it
makes perfect [ __ ] sense
it truly does it's i love how he just
drove home that like
you listen to this advice and you take
it you go on your own path and when you
make it you look back and you drop that
[ __ ] knowledge because that's how i
feel too i was doing that [ __ ]
back in my lyrics in buffalo as if
i was already here trying to inspire
some make-believe [ __ ] crowd you know
but i i love that like i i love i love
that like it's an obligation if you're
lucky enough to make something happen
and
it's what you're passionate about and
you get out there and people are
watching you it's your duty
to to just give this overall message
back yeah
love that [ __ ] yeah dude i totally
[ __ ] get it now it's weird
but oh sorry
i'm not just bringing up you're gonna be
rich you're just that's not what i'm
saying i'm i just know it
so when people like think about it
[ __ ] see what you're gonna do like i
know what i'm gonna do i don't know what
it is gonna be yet that's what i say
when i was like 25 and go i don't know
how
but i'm going to make this [ __ ] larger
than weak the how does it matter yeah i
was like i don't know how but i know i
will
that was the main thing from the secret
that i took it's in the book like that
the the how doesn't matter don't don't
get all caught up in the house
caught up in the end result of where
you're trying to be
and then just like the dude that wrote
chicken noodle soup for the soul jack
canfield i think i said this before but
it's the best quote ever you can drive
across from new york to california in
the dark with just your headlights on
seeing 15 feet in front of you it
unrolls as you keep driving
the light keeps pushing forward and you
just
take it as it comes but you know you
know you have in mind where you want to
end up
i love that that's how you got to do it
exactly how i live my life just trying
to do whatever i can do right now what
can i do what's in front of me yes
before we started the dopest and before
we started a couple
this too i told rosie like i don't know
i said like there's a certain amount of
money i'm trying to make in one not
because i want money it's because
i gotta pay for this i gotta pay for
this i can start a new project i can
start this we can start a new business
we can do that more push trees gear
there's never been like a oh [ __ ] yeah i
got a lot of money it's always oh wow i
can buy new products it's capital it's
different than money yeah how to [ __ ]
the money like i never really give a
[ __ ] about that i only care about oh can
i get my house oh [ __ ] that involves
money i gotta save money
you know that's the way my brain works
like i don't give a [ __ ] about being
bummed
when i the first couple years that i
lived here it was like it seems i would
look at other people like
that own houses and [ __ ] out here which
is like the average person
like they were just different like damn
i don't know how i'm ever gonna be able
to cross this chasm and i need [ __ ]
need to so bad
like all my kids parent friend you know
friends parents and [ __ ] at the soccer
games just driving around looking at
houses like
how could this ever be [ __ ] possible
i get it
you're like you know i know it will but
how is it even i don't believe it but i
do believe it yeah yeah you like you
doubt yourself at the same time i know
it's gonna happen but man i [ __ ]
don't know how i sure [ __ ] hope it
does
but i'm gonna put my head down until it
does yep or until i [ __ ] die
just keep trying [ __ ] it
this turn this level that we got to do
like
i tried as hard as i could yeah
it's just such affirmation for me that
all of this is happening and the
feedback we get from the fans just makes
me want to just be like this [ __ ] is
real
there's no denying the [ __ ] that we're
talking about like you can look back at
your path and my path and everybody's
path and
i just i love that this is a place where
people can come and get inspired and
motivated every monday and come chill
and we're not on some [ __ ] nerd [ __ ]
monday motivations
i love that hell yeah i love that yeah
yo the what motivates me because you
know i love movies so much and we talk
about it all the time and we just
referenced it
it's not the fact because i know people
like it's materialistic you're just
talking about money like you want to get
my
listen to me
when 50 sent through that [ __ ] bag
and didn't have to do paperwork and
bought the [ __ ] white bands and drove
off
when i watched that i went oh my [ __ ]
god this broke [ __ ] started
coming up look at this [ __ ]
it wasn't damn this fool's got money it
was holy [ __ ] one day if i could do that
that means everybody in my family's not
[ __ ] up and we're doing good and then
i had enough money to go left over in
the car that's what you're supposed to
think when you see shiny [ __ ] that's my
thing like i gotta get this i gotta no
the subtle see your rims on a car is
you're supposed to think oh this
motherfucker's got so much money that
he's run out of [ __ ] to [ __ ] spend on
so now he's getting shiny ass rims
that's what you're supposed to think in
actuality he's in his [ __ ] mom's
basement and
eats like [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] child support
yeah but you you get it you get it yeah
that's what i that's what motivates me
is thinking of that
and he's driving around like
he's excited that's one of the best
scenes and one of the best scenes in any
movie i've watched i love you that's the
last one
i don't even know my name no more they
just keep calling me handsome
i love 50 cent i love that part they
just keep calling me handsome that's the
one moment in the movie where he laughs
and [ __ ] yeah he smiles shows teeth
gangsta grandpa in the produce uh-huh yo
50 cent come on the [ __ ] show one day
come on i would love to have it
imagine you tell me about the story
talking man he's gonna be like oh i know
what that was i remember that [ __ ]
call this bottom of the world that was
vitamin ah i know he remembers it
he was [ __ ] pissed he was [ __ ]
pissed
yo dude finney sam i love that for he's
so [ __ ] funny bro his social media is
great know what happened we've just been
ranting for a minute i forgot we were
podcasting
right i was just looking at him look at
the camera just looking past like
[ __ ] 50 cent man um
i remember oh yeah so the motivation for
me that's what motivates me a lot a lot
like it's not
trying to get money it's like holy [ __ ]
i was able to do everything else and
then get that
oh my god
that's how i think
also i really really love when people go
oh you're it's you
i love that because they look at me to
some
high kid in bands like who's this fat
kid you go oh it's me man thanks how you
doing nice to meet you knowner the owner
yeah they're like
yes yes yes
exactly that's the point kids that's the
[ __ ] point
in this age that we live in that's how
it can be
you can be you
and be out here and get your money and
[ __ ] thank you b i said that it's on
twitter yesterday like just if i have
any advice for anybody on earth just be
yourself
there's nothing better in the world than
acting like you anywhere you go
love it love it well i mean i get i i
act different in crowds i'm not as
talkative because i don't [ __ ] know
you
you know what i'm saying i'm a lot
quieter in [ __ ]
crowds or in the lobby at a hotel i'm a
very quiet person yeah but what i'm
talking about i'm talking to people like
talking to people that's different i
know you or if we spark a conversation
i'm going to talk to you normally
and then you're like oh this talks a lot
but that's what i'm saying um
you can be yourself anywhere and i you
always have to be and i've said it
before the thing that made me like
yeah i'm gonna crush this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
is when i got that house and clack and
uh merced
and the [ __ ] dude that was a little
bit older than me i opened the door
wait what's up man so is your dad home
like nah that's my house
he's like
[Laughter]
so so is your mom or dad home go bro
this is my house
he looks at me he looks at this guy he
goes
you live
do this here
my house what's up
and i remember i opened the door i go
what do you what's up man
i'm like you know what i'm just gonna
close the door on you what do you want
it was like a telemarketer believe in me
like
yo
yeah like they're [ __ ] with me i just
didn't understand
uh in person telemarketer essentially
and the guy was so like
kind of bummed
i'm like bro wouldn't you be like [ __ ]
yeah bro good [ __ ] that's how i if i
walked on
yeah
[ __ ] it
and then the same thing happened with
the neighbor like they were [ __ ] just
like no
who lives here and i'm like all right
man i'm gonna go
same thing you're not party animals
right
all right i'm gonna close the door on
you we had one of our neighbors was
a house that got took over by this pack
of 14 year old puerto rican kids
say the whole sentence again
sorry i got so lost i was watching the
puerto rican day parade episode of
seinfeld last night and when i heard
puerto rican i just heard of thought
kramer jumping into the wrong car sorry
say the whole sentence again my brain
sucks we moved into this house on
[ __ ] south side parkway in buffalo
and the neighbors was this puerto rican
family it was a duplex
there was only they were in the bottom
and nobody was in the top and the mom
would be on the porch once a while go
over there and talk to her she had all
these [ __ ] kids and then eventually
the mom just peaced out at some point
and these [ __ ] kids she just ran the
whole house so there'd be [ __ ] 10 of
them posted up on the porch at all times
so
when we first moved in
they were like i'm like this is gonna be
a [ __ ] issue cause right away they're
talking to april's friends they're like
talking [ __ ] whatever they're not you
know i mean like hollering at them and
[ __ ] oh they're kids okay i get it i get
it i get it
but they always got their [ __ ] music
on super loud ariana was a baby it was
just i mean this was a [ __ ] trapped
out [ __ ] little block that we were on
big time yeah and uh not much you could
really do man
but one we came home from work one day
and all we could smell was natural gas
like
bad
so we called the fire department and
there was a a serious natural gas leak
out of the back of the house they came
fire trucks they all came
nobody was even at the house at the time
they fixed it whatever
two days two days later i remember this
it's christmas
we smell burning
and i'm like i think the christmas
lights are on fire and i look outside
directly next door in the house there's
a truck
in the drive in their
front lawn
completely engulfed in flames
of this house that just had this [ __ ]
gas leak like days before gonna kill a
whole block i know i just said man you
painted such a good picture you lived
upstairs i mean i'm imagining concrete
slabs with the black railing and some
bushes yeah basically i'm just
i got pictures of this [ __ ] and that
yeah so fire fire department right back
out there
huh who's truck i don't know it was just
on fire it might have crashed there i
don't know how it got there i've never
seen the truck before it was not crashed
but it was up on the [ __ ] almost to
the house the [ __ ] was lit on fire
and then i then like
shortly after we moved in i saw one of
my like young boys from lackawanna and
[ __ ] over there and i was like okay it's
all good like oh okay he just it was
always all good from that point but yeah
when he said that [ __ ] about that
they really took the whole [ __ ] thing
over damn
that's the [ __ ] peter pan [ __ ]
yeah yeah
or not i mean a little video the other
day and it goes you want me to [ __ ] your
mind up i go oh my god i see a picture
of captain hook i'm gonna watch you got
me intrigued
i see cartoon dustin hoffman all right
here we go
and it says
imagine this
what if captain hook isn't the bad guy
peter pan is essentially kidnapping your
kids
in the night and stealing them to a
[ __ ] island
captain hook is just one of the kids
that grew up and is trying to take peter
pan down to stop kidnapping all the
[ __ ] kids
oh my god
yeah i guess you're right like i never
thought about it peter pan is a [ __ ]
18 year old kid in tights that steals
your [ __ ] kits
i thought they're all orphans no they
came back remember okay yeah i know they
had their [ __ ] they came back
and the mom was losing their [ __ ]
that's true yeah that was some that was
borderline kidnapping from peter yeah he
kidnapped the whole [ __ ] family
but the parents
remember yeah what the [ __ ] peter pan's
kind of [ __ ] up i gotta go back and
watch that again with this now peter
pan's kind of [ __ ]
now that i think i still [ __ ] love
andy i mean i'm just loving it he was
coming back he was a little old to be
stealing the little girl at some point
right
let's just stay
stay with the we love cook
yeah but you see what i'm saying
so i saw that meme went sometimes the
internet is great because that expanded
i love that everything
um
i completely forgot what i was about to
talk about
that blew my [ __ ] mind oh yeah i saw
that [ __ ] on the internet it [ __ ] me
up all right damn it damn it reminded me
of that [ __ ] twitter [ __ ] you were
talking about earlier for some reason
with the uh
the wrestler
or that [ __ ] oh my god right now guys
are you guys ready
are you guys [ __ ] ready
so if you're on twitter i need you to
find the iron sheik
i need you guys you guys know who the
iron sheik is
bam he's popped up on the screen right
right now right now exactly
okay the iron cheek is a wrestler
and the man is can you look up his age
real quick yeah real quick guys i didn't
know i just saw a tweet and i went
died laughing and looked at an angle is
that really the iron cheek this man is
80 years old shut the [ __ ] up 1942. are
you kidding
he it was his birthday yesterday he said
happy birthday birthday to myself
yesterday go [ __ ] yourself
are you guys ready
i think i found the best twitter of all
time the iron sheik i said he's a
seven-year-old man at least the iron
cheek is an 80 year old man he's in his
eighth decade of life
he has the best twitter i've ever seen i
told marty today look there's almost 29
000. there's 29 000 tweets
he's tweeted on this account
and all of them are in all caps
and he posts 30 a day
and they're so
[ __ ] funny
everything ends with go [ __ ] yourself
unapologetically go [ __ ] yourself
uh daylight saving times go [ __ ]
yourself you know what [ __ ] hulk hogan
just
i mean it doesn't i told marty how long
did i go for early about 10 minutes yeah
i was amazing reading them all like
marty marty
hygienically go [ __ ] yourself
take a minute of your day to be nice and
take a minute of your day to be nice to
someone you dumb son of a [ __ ]
just [ __ ] like that over and over
i didn't know he was 80 it makes it
better sorry not sorry go [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
what's his what's his twitter
uh at
the underscore iron sheath the
underscore iron gik the ex-wrestler guys
please he has a vendetta against hulk
hogan i mean he shits on him on twitter
he shits off [ __ ] hulk hogan from this
day forward go [ __ ] yourself
24 7 365 go [ __ ] yourself
i'm telling you this man is so [ __ ]
cool
he's so cool
let's just stop talking about that
because youtube's going to flag us
automatically actually marty is there a
way we could take this whole part out
it might honestly let's go babe guys if
you saw a bleep right there
we took a little part out because
honestly we might get age-restricted and
flagged for what we just talked about
there might be a new restriction for
that one yes we it's nothing crazy you
guys are but you're leaving us hanging
now no we talked about something about
some stuff on the news and it's probably
trigger words let's just leave it at
that
babe
i crushed this can out of fright
i was like oh man maybe we should be
talking about that stuff
they're gonna [ __ ] they're gonna get mad
go follow iron shoe ball iron cheek is
what we're trying to say he's funny
marty went hard
we opened up a whole candle this is the
rolex man
it's the rolex this is not my
my mama's table
i just want everybody to know you know
what you can that gets universal uh-huh
put some panties let's keep going sorry
go watch get rich or die trying
how about that we've been promoting the
[ __ ] out of that we've been promoting
them i love that movie uncle john used
to watch so much
so much
gangster grandpa i'm proud of it all
right we gotta move on sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry yo we have
been on a tangent for about 45 minutes
uh that's what we're here for today
folks what are we on 1 15.
we're going to do it i think we're going
to do it here we go are you ready
hey what's up guys welcome to the mid
roll ad read huge shout out to one of
our long time sponsors this is manscaped
you've heard it many ad reads guys their
slogan is your balls will thank you the
slogan we made up on the dope as usual
show is don't have a gross dick they
both work okay we say it all the time
guys whoever writes the emails for
manscapes to send it to us i love you
the first line says splish splash i was
taking a bath and i noticed i have
beautiful balls
that's funny besides all the funny stuff
guys this is the mail grooming kit they
have much more than just razors but
before we get into that go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yolo
that's 20 off of anything and everything
on the entire site your whole order and
free shipping let's hop straight into
the latest products they just introduced
the lip balm they recently released the
two in one shampoo conditioner you got
the travel bag the underwear the nose
trimmer lawnmower 4.0 but like i said
there's endless products there's not
even enough time to name everything so
do me a favor go to manscape.com forward
slash yolo yola is the actual checkout
code that's what gets you the discount
remember 20 off of everything in the
entire site your whole order plus free
shipping so there it is guys that's
everything for manscape go ahead and
check it out don't forget to use our
code now back to the episode
right now there's a new set being built
all right if you watched any of my last
open sola videos
that was the last video of that set
done i've had the same set since i
really started going hard on youtube in
2018. and you've managed to recreate it
like three times you guys you couldn't
even tell that we moved
we moved three times since we started
youtube and my look has not changed
because i've
i try to keep it wayne's world i want
you to come back and see oh it sucks and
it cuts i want you to remember like oh i
know where the couch is i know where the
stairs are i know where that picture you
know what i mean that's why i want you
to see like we have a very basic setup
marty what's our setup looking like
the [ __ ] is looking awfully [ __ ]
leveled up i wouldn't even it's not even
the same thing
like before was very og very classic you
and your apartment this is
showing like the success of story time
like it's you trying to really give back
to the fans to level it up to to keep it
keep it going better and better in terms
of quality and just
giving back to the fans for all the
views and all the engagement by making
it better i mean you're not you could
have very easily just
started season four
we just set that [ __ ] room up
less than a year ago yeah
so
the fact that you did all this
is a lot of money a lot of time a lot of
effort a lot of energy trent the whole
team everybody's working my friend bong
doctor trent and it looks [ __ ] clean
he's good yeah he's really good he
designed the set
we did it we're picking out stuff right
now marty that's only about
25 percent done 30. we're not even done
yet we still have a bunch of stuff to
put up there in the lights
it is gonna be
awesome
story time season four just the talking
is gonna look great
normal reviews me doing stuff
talking and anything in the studio
leveled up wow twitch added to the phone
twitch added to the roster there's a
whole twitch part of the room basically
here's story time that way boom
open the curtains install the into the
roof everything done move the throne
chair
boom there's the twit station curtains
to the side like a theater so you see
red curtains on the side super sick ass
wall we're painting all the the neon
lights are going up we're installing big
giant frame doorway window style things
on the wall yo trent cut a hole in the
wall added a window inside of the room
just so we can air it out because it's
so smoky that's why we did genius we're
wow
one day he'll be on here he's he'd be a
[ __ ] amazing guest
he's here right now i mean he's going
back tomorrow i mean i'll see him in
like six hours yeah
i'm so tired
it's okay trent lives in hawaii he lives
in hawaii he's from fresno clovis where
they're near where i'm from he used to
be the bong doctor he used to make a
bunch of glass he's a super my first
piece of glass i ever got
had my [ __ ] name on it
from trent
such a [ __ ] g my first weed party
i had my shitty little dab pen you guys
were [ __ ] doing giant
i can't believe you're in the video
and you know what's so crazy is i
remember somebody that i didn't know
like because we all knew jeremy oh yeah
no i was the outsider i was i didn't
know anybody yeah that was like one of
their story in my life what's up what's
up how you guys doing how are you guys
doing
making the video throwing the thing
oh that [ __ ] is crazy it's so crazy yeah
it's so wild it really is years later
coming back is insane yeah
and the people that through that party
are [ __ ] pieces of she don't even
[ __ ] with those people anymore not trent
the the you know who talked about this
other
edible people anyway
it's just so weird
it's so wild this is to sit so anyway
the set just seeing the level and from
trent my homie actually doing this
he's so [ __ ] good at this and our set
and the twitch everything is looking so
bomb that we're installing i forgot to
we saw all the leds
on the top of the black things
so it's gonna look like i'm glowing i
love a [ __ ] that knows lighting
he said lightning expert that's what
trent does when he's do filming like he
films but he's like the lighting is what
he does light is an art people wouldn't
realize it it [ __ ] get on sets but
there's a whole industry around lighting
and it's like i believe the biggest
factors in video you can have a great
camera a [ __ ] really pretty model
sick ass background have the best ever
and if your lighting sucks your picture
[ __ ] sucks
it's true
can't bring out a raw picture if it's
[ __ ] dusk
and there's nothing there's nothing to
bring out it's [ __ ] dark you want it
to be grainy
that's it it's over you [ __ ]
one iphone light save this today
you know how many people have probably
held an iphone light over some of your
favorite pictures just because it was so
dark
it's crazy but yeah shout out to trent
the set is looking [ __ ]
super cool
next week will be the first uh time you
see it i think next week or maybe the
following week because i'm gonna film
probably sunday or monday i have another
video done already story time all the
studio stuff i've done i sent i sent it
off to the fx guy
and if you're not following that yolo of
adventures channel go follow that thank
you thank you i always forget the
adventures of yola on youtube i have a
second channel
it's third channel well a third channel
yeah i have a third channel it's
completely clean i do stuff that's
family friendly i'm trying to get on
youtube's good side and they actually do
recommend my videos and it's crazy
because i'm monetized on there i don't
like [ __ ] but uh monetized on there it's
[ __ ] awesome so nicely since we got a
call now we're starting to shout out to
cole shout out to [ __ ] cole he did
three videos for me this week
a life changer probably added three
[ __ ] videos for me this week
crushing it i love the little graphics
you're throwing in there cole and if
you're watching this you [ __ ] yes
crush it
let's go good job
love it all um
yeah so the set's looking great
everything's i'm [ __ ] high the set's
looking good we're at what 123.
still got it yes
here we go i'm trying to get it here we
go so let's move on
new sets coming story time is coming
season four uh we ran into uh oh i don't
even talk i haven't seen you guys oh we
rented a [ __ ] fake plane studio the
story is about a plane and we rented a
[ __ ] studio that has a fake half a
plane with a green screen surrounded in
the room
that's all i'm gonna say all right let's
just say that all right yeah the studio
is not the only way you're leveling up
story time
oh yeah story time's gonna be
just wait i'm very excited i'm very
excited it's taking a while i know it
but
i'm gonna put three out as fast as i
possibly can to catch up for the times i
missed this past two months
i promise and remember i said it in
talking with thomas episode
eat a dick if you're going to talk [ __ ]
i have to pay for all this myself so
[ __ ] you
it's not cheap
right it's not [ __ ] cheap and it's
not the only thing you put out you got
hella dope is the ola vlogs popping off
you got the [ __ ] adventures you got a
new podcast episode every week yeah so
we're trying you got the we tube [ __ ]
yeah and we too man oh there's there's a
lot going on but thank you guys thank
you so much
um on to my next one
oh wait
that was my next one we talked about
story time i'm [ __ ] can we just say
two 20 million views and listens in the
first year guys is it 20 now combined
yeah
where's that [ __ ] horn yeah i
know we got it
we got it's probably actually more than
that
20 million and the first year shout out
to you guys the the listen hours or the
minutes
was on incomprehensible week i didn't do
the math but the month of june was one
of our higher months and there was 770
million watch time minutes
in 30 days it's got a rival a lot of
netflix series i would think i don't
know but wow
nice
thanks
you guys are telling the [ __ ] homie
thanks yeah you guys are really telling
people it's weird huh marty because
you've always been behind the camera and
now you're okay and i'm telling you i go
through all the comments
and i go through some of the old ones
just to check up on [ __ ] see how we used
to film i do it all the time just to
look i see a lot of comments like oh
marty you actually the first episode you
start talking people like hey marty
should talk more he finally started
talking and i remember looking at my old
comments like yeah i bet you'll start
talking a lot more it's gonna be great
and that was like a [ __ ] year ago and
i'm looking at like yeah the show would
[ __ ] suck it was just me talking all
the time
it's awesome it's gotta it's gotta and
it's wild cause he's like i never
thought i've had like fans
congratulating me on the [ __ ] house
and [ __ ] it makes life so much different
it's different because when you came
here like music music i'm gonna [ __ ]
do this through music now you're like
podcasting i'm going to help out with
pogba and then [ __ ] make our own
people actually know
me
know like about you know the fans
they've been listening dude this is a
story time every week we're telling
stories different life as life happens
it's like different now yeah yeah we're
updating our [ __ ] homies our virtual
homies every week what's happening
the [ __ ] the bad [ __ ] that's happening
the dope [ __ ] that's happening
exactly
here it is you know what's going on yeah
and people know like you know our path
and what it took to get here so that's
you know most of all yeah
you've been here so thank you guys
it's all right guys for real and [ __ ]
crazy keep this momentum going and we're
gonna keep leveling this [ __ ] up and
getting bigger and better [ __ ] going on
100
yeah dude we we uh
uploaded the
josh
we uh got uploaded youtube four days
early three days early [ __ ] yeah and
i just went premiere because if i wait
the day they're gonna be like oh where
are you experiencing somebody
like all goes out tuesday now like the
[ __ ] so i would know post it and
people kept going
does this mean we're getting close to
two episodes a week
oh my god that would be [ __ ] amazing
marty if we did what we were trying to
do we won't talk about that yet if we do
we're trying to do with what we're
trying to do and set it up yeah we could
do that yeah we will walk
out
yeah i mean we have a podcast worth a
conversation every day anyway yes
[ __ ] yes we do
i just i know every time i'm about to
face time i go
it's a quick call but i know it's gonna
be like 35 minutes all right i'm good
yeah i'm good what's up that's how you
got to do it when you got a small
operation like this it's it never stops
it's it's [ __ ] it's all the time
seven days a week you're asleep you've
been going to sleep early like on time
yeah so i've been trying to hit you past
like ten
cause i'm like nah this fool's finally
falling asleep on time let me just leave
this will be i'll get there one day i'll
talk to him in the morning
um but now i've been going to that
[ __ ] trainer so i have been again to
get up
[ __ ] [ __ ] let's [ __ ] go
how many in like four or five now i
don't even know man good answer
i just feel sick you're talking about a
personal trainer with rosie
yeah yeah me rosie got a personal
trainer and randomly the dude that owns
he's like
we saw the same sticker we had for the
shovel for the system of a damn corncon
we saw on his laptop like
sick and he's like yeah yeah blah blah
blah i trained shower's wife
oh sick i know him he's just tight so oh
you know my game he's cool
i'm not gonna be like yeah i know chavo
we're really [ __ ] good friends i just
went yeah season one episode three i was
like he's he's a cool guy that's uh yeah
that's how always he's such a cool guy
like josh real quick josh i remember one
time he's talking about yeah but for me
my friend billy are just chilling well
well i'm like oh cool
this is when i was like a year into
doing instagram [ __ ] and then like two
days later i saw him post
had fun the other day bro we gotta do it
again and he posted with the person he
was talking about billy and i went
you're so nonchalant you're so [ __ ]
subtle with your life josh you [ __ ]
rock star
and it was billy corgan smashing
pumpkins i was like
what this is the bill you're having
lunch with when i called you
sick
i love slashing pumpkins tight i just
remember thinking
that's tight that's cool i remember
[Music]
i moved into the apartment real quick i
moved to the apartment
my first apartment jeebs on park avenue
and the first night we really set our
[ __ ] up
i had an ipod
right and i'm like oh [ __ ] yes first
ipod i ever had just had a hell of a
song that's when i why i know every
lyric to 300 bars and running for some
[ __ ] let's go
i can see the whole thing right now it's
crazy
that's really oh here we go it's
starting game said that's why they
didn't want him at the super bowl
because he was going to come out and do
that [ __ ]
oh you can't do that he was joking but
that's [ __ ] funny oh you can't do
that man 50 cent's hard he comes out and
does that [ __ ]
diss track from 20 years ago dude i i
didn't even know i didn't even listen to
the gas member okay 300.17 oh my well
let me listen to this
because we're just talking about how
much elephant you say i'm out here just
[ __ ] on fools i just went
wow
that's crazy i'm really high
what was i talking about that was eight
seconds ago i said i want to take a
oh yeah so the first time i started
getting my cd collection i was trapping
hard as hell but my sister worked the
street light records and her homie shout
out to ralph uh her homie her roommate
ralph was uh one of the managers of
streetlight
give me the family discount that's why i
have a extensive cd collection i mean i
got some
cool g rap [ __ ] yeah
original prince and like
deltron 30 30 instrumental and it says
like out of print on it and i remember
getting like this is the instrumentals
have you ever listened to deltron 3030
no
one of the best albums ever [ __ ] made
of all time
it's [ __ ] amazing dale the funky homo
sapien from hieroglyphics
and i think it's dan the automator i
don't know if people understand your
[ __ ] underground hip-hop knowledge
because it is intense a [ __ ] good
album i can't remember i can't remember
if his name is dan the automator it's
something to automate i think it's dan
i'm so [ __ ] bad with that
i'm bad with dj names and producers i do
know that i [ __ ] suck with that [ __ ]
anyway dan the automator yeah dan the
automator
i'm sitting there and i'm like
my friend dude shout out to deuce he hit
me i'm like yo let's name some
[ __ ] i'm going to the cd shop i
need to [ __ ] grab some new [ __ ]
expand my [ __ ] mind that's why i
started listening to yuck mouth a lot
[ __ ] now he's like my homie and it's
[ __ ] weird
shout out to you he's cool as [ __ ] that
fool's girl very [ __ ] funny he needs
scats
yeah good [ __ ]
sorry anyway off the [ __ ] topic
i'm sitting there
and i'm like yo all right atmosphere
turn to be one of my [ __ ] favorite
groups of all time and slug is my
favorite rapper of all time and if
anybody's ever asked me that was your
favorite rapper it's slug from
atmosphere it always will be
love them
my favorite [ __ ] if we get [ __ ]
slugging you i'd lose my [ __ ] i'd be so
stoked
anyway it's my favorite rapper of all
time
and it's the first night i ever heard
listen to atmosphere i put the cd on
put the cd on
and i didn't have the headphones uh i
put the cd on and played it and i smoked
bowls
i smoked
for like four hours straight
i was trying to go to sleep because i
had to go to work
i spoke like four hours straight listen
to atmosphere and i remember just
listening to this [ __ ] like whoa
this is some other type of music and i
just started my brain just went pop up
and i started listening to so many
[ __ ] different kind of hip hop
and that's when i really started loving
atmosphere but the reason i bring it up
because we were just talking about like
weird [ __ ] like when you're a kid
and you're like yo my friend's uncle yo
that full med snoop dogg at a [ __ ]
concert you know when you're 15 like
what the [ __ ] you met
snooped what
it's mind-blowing especially from a
small town like you've met him what are
you
because when you see you think of famous
people when you're a kid you think of
them as
unfeasible characters larger than life
type [ __ ] like no brett favre is not a
real guy he's just brett favre on the tv
great quarter you know what i mean you
don't think like he's a real person
so i remember i was listening to the app
i bought like five atmosphere cds that's
how hard i went like on deuce's [ __ ]
recommendation i bought like five cds
but god loves ugly is the first one i
put on i went whoa this [ __ ] is
too tight and my favorite song
love life is my favorite song hip hop
song
anyway
um
so there's a lyric i can't remember what
album is but slug says
uh all now all my friends are famous one
it's either one thing or another and i
remember thinking when i was a kid like
how weird is it that
you just have a job you get to talk to
people that you like
and famous fools
and then your friends
isn't that a weird thing you know what
i'm saying martin isn't that so odd
i would hear that late the reason i
brought all that up because that one
lyric sorry i tell stories that one
lyric and he said now all my friends are
famous either one thing or another oh i
think it's on uh
sevens travis no it's on uh the one we
got a [ __ ] mohawk and he's sitting
there [ __ ] i can't remember the names of
the cd [ __ ]
anyway
um
i remember thinking isn't it weird that
you know famous people because you it's
unfathomable as a kid so marty now when
i'm looking around it's like
it's so odd because you never think
about [ __ ] and i look
and sometimes i'm like on my phone i get
text i'm like this is just the oddest
thing in my life mm-hmm people i used to
watch on tv i'm like yo trying to get
high yeah yeah
that was dr drew for me i was like this
is trippy
i've learned so much life advice from
this phone now he's in here talking like
that was weird it's weird
it's not you don't ever think about it
but when you think about you go
wow yeah so when i thought somebody
asked me today how odd is it that you're
from merced but now you're [ __ ]
chilling with uh he's all chong and i
see you chilling with [ __ ] chum like
i never thought about it yeah you don't
think about it like that don't think
about that ever it's just like yo let's
get this [ __ ] episode in this could
be a good one i want to conversate with
this man he's so sick you don't think
like oh my god oh [ __ ] yeah it's like
thank god we he he said he'd come on and
listen
yeah let's get this [ __ ] [ __ ] up he
went on story time i was like
whoa he came on story time on my channel
two years ago it was
[ __ ] insane
but you know what i'm saying my mom even
text me dude
you're [ __ ] chilling with chong i'm
like
wow
that's right because my mom you know i
mean she's from the same place i am
except i just came to la
so that's how i used to think like what
it's like yo this is so weird how weird
is it you used to watch this when you
were a kid the [ __ ] and now you're like
smoking joints and just chilling
it is odd but i think of that lyric
every time i get a weird text i'm like
this is so odd
it's so weird i know so many people from
so many walks of life from doing so much
[ __ ] all from i love weed
and i like to make fools laugh
and it just kept going it's so [ __ ]
weird sorry i'm coming to the conclusion
that
i finally realized like yeah it is kind
of odd i never thought about it like
that before but somebody dm how weird is
it that you're from like
i guess it is kind of crazy huh and
somebody dm me the other day like yo my
mom went to tanaya middle school with
you
you're my oh yeah you have kids at like
15 percent okay who's your mom who had a
kid when we were kids oh i know your mom
is you know through [ __ ] like that i
went
your son
is now watching my [ __ ] and he's in
middle school
it's like i'm not even that old
[ __ ] damn but it's weird like
it's coming like
my friends kids are getting to where
like yo everyone talks about being
highest one yep i've had that i've i've
sent hoodies to kids back in buffalo
that are friendly you know what i'm
saying
crazy [ __ ] man
so now i think about me being a little
like looking up like wow [ __ ] and just i
don't know i'm just saying like it's a
surreal feeling like
weird
weird i have so many of your cds now
we're just kidding
[Music]
really i know you just got it's like
just kind of [ __ ] wrong with that
yeah i never think about it ever i never
think until sometime like
isn't this so hard and i've been kicking
back like even in the last episode i'll
be like oh look at that nice seamless
transition this motherfucker's an
interviewer like
really really you're evolving as an
interviewer
i'm trying my best bro i've been trying
to not interrupt [ __ ] and like
i just did to you i've been trying to
not do that no
i'm sure thank you yeah i've been trying
like really trying to geraldo rivera my
ass like so
let's move on
with all different types of people and
yeah
it's like anything else it's like
getting your [ __ ] jump shot down it's
just reps yep that's what it's doing
right now because right now i can sit in
front of a [ __ ] stadium and do this
i'm just not gonna bug me mm-hmm it's
cool yeah i'd be more hyped yeah i'd be
way more hyper yeah
i feel like we bring everybody kind of
into art we bring everybody into our
show like we all we always end up kind
of talking about the same [ __ ] same life
[ __ ] with
most guests with real guests but it's
their perspective and that's the most
fun like i say we're the same
[ __ ] different times of our
lives and that's how you get to see
josh when you popped out that picture of
him at like 20
yeah
yep
[Laughter]
josh
you're probably the coolest [ __ ]
you still are but like as that age being
that dope as a kid
that's pretty wild
so you think about like yeah i know some
[ __ ] like that well we're gonna
be oh it's gonna be great because now i
look i was talking to my friend the
other day i have a lot of friends that
used to have illegal companies and now
they're legal they did other [ __ ] and
they're [ __ ] balling so it's wild to
see fools that
were broke like keep going keep going
keep trying keep trying and they [ __ ]
did it
like a lot like 60 of my friend group
has already done has already crushed it
and it's so [ __ ] weird to look at it
and see old pictures and when i see old
pictures like i don't look like look
that much younger
neither do you
but it's been a long time a lot has
happened remember how broke we were
right there
like trying to still try thinking like
no keep going keep going keep going and
i'm not going to say who but one of my
friends just kept going kept going
trying this trying this trying and it
finally popped off and this falls
millions and
millions a month deep i feel i never
asked i'm not gonna ask but just from
like
another
hyper car
all right crush it crushing it
another oh the new one yeah meanwhile go
check out that new lambo video on the
phone i don't even think i'm talking
about it yeah i know i'm saying that
[ __ ] we were talking about that [ __ ]
sounded scary i'll watch the adventures
of yola video and go watch the ten
thousand dollar shopping spree
go watch that [ __ ] demonic lambo injured
my homies got some like matching lambos
that are
disgusting so loud and
they're so sick who's got the matching
lambo truck and the lambo and they're
both sky blue with the blacks
some gta shows it's some gt every time
my brother
bronco is that's when he look at rocco's
still me when i was younger so he always
texts me like
bro that's so tight
it is tight that was a good [ __ ]
interview you're right
because i'm just thinking it was like
yeah we're [ __ ] all right i can't
imagine what i don't know
that's his favorite car ever mm-hmm oh
so real quick my little brother rocco
just graduated [ __ ] high school he's
done [ __ ] awesome i'm trying to move
him out here
yeah
you know he's watching this [ __ ] at the
gym most likely my little brother rocco
is our push trees model you guys know
that he graduated omar shout out to
ratchet man he knows somebody at ripon
dip so i go yo let me buy some [ __ ] for
my brother because we always go to rip
and dip it's his favorite [ __ ] brand
we always go to rip and dip on on
fairfax
we're in there
and we're talking to somebody and they
have a tech deck thing in the middle of
their store
and we're talking to somebody and he's
cool i'm chilling with some dude like yo
what's up man how are you doing we're
just doing tech deck [ __ ] blah blah blah
i didn't realize that's the guy that we
came to meet with omar with ratchet man
sorry
and we're just doing i'm like oh okay
nice to meet you bro thank you so much
for having us in i'm you know we're
doing the whole thing we're filming i'm
buying my brother some [ __ ]
i didn't realize till after this the
[ __ ] the creator owner of rip and dip
it's the [ __ ] owner that came out to
meet us because he's like yo can we film
and the guy was so [ __ ] we're just in
the trying to [ __ ] take deck i'm like
oh yeah i'm a nice store man he's like
yeah we had a billboard i didn't realize
he was the [ __ ] owner so hold on he
didn't say he didn't i didn't know i
thought he was a marketing people oh
okay i didn't ask him i'm like yo i know
you know some people that rip and dip i
didn't know he was the [ __ ] all
omar knows everybody yeah i was gonna
say you know it's [ __ ] everybody does
so the guys super cool shout out to ryan
[ __ ] he [ __ ] post my little
brother on rip and dip [ __ ] and i mean
when we left and i said oh we did
well he's my little brother like picking
[ __ ] out he it like shopping people
shopping but you can see it's my little
brother like
oh [ __ ] you know he's he's a kid he's
like wow my favorite brand wow and so we
go you know justin boyd shout out to him
we go and do a whole photo shoot
shout out to uh rip and dip um they hit
us up like two days later and he's like
yo ratchet man you're homing thomas
that kid that he brought in can we use
him for some pictures i know that he's
doing some modeling [ __ ] he goes we have
a new ripping dip catalog coming out no
[ __ ] i didn't know that i tell you no
i was wondering he hit a [ __ ] ratchet
man he's like yo can we use that kid
that you brought in for the new catalog
wow mission accomplished he's like we'll
get the date we'll come in and we'll
shoot with him wow
mission damn let's go that was [ __ ]
fast the video just dropped no it was
the day or the next day after we came in
before it even dropped oh the next day
after okay yeah yeah he came in the next
day he's like yo damn i started posting
her uncle like yo look two days later i
was like damn my little brother's gonna
be a [ __ ] model watch this [ __ ] i
have a feeling he's gonna be like some
burberry [ __ ] runway kid
we have different dads he's like six
[ __ ] two
he's six two with like
oh like what's so [ __ ] lengthy
yeah he looks like the runway kid so
yeah
[ __ ] shout out to the ripping dude
appreciate you guys little brother is
[ __ ]
hyped bro girl he is so [ __ ] excited
so yeah
that little whole thing happened with
the anyway that's that day is inside the
ten thousand dollar shopping spree video
that is on that's what it's called on
the adventures of yolo channel so it's
three videos it's like three or four
vlogs squished together but it was the
same day
it was awesome man it was a long day but
fun super fun
um i think that's all my stories and i
think we're at what 1 33 i messed up 43.
ah you [ __ ] we did close we
tried i tried my best guys i love the
smash mother life cam that [ __ ] is
appropriate it was when we started
talking about stuff we shouldn't have
been talking about and i go yo
let's cut this part out we're gonna get
in trouble
so let's just leave it at that and
you'll never know
[Music]
everybody driving don't get some ass
mister don't drive
like no we're not saying we're into asmr
sex stuff [ __ ] we're saying
that's what it's called
that episode's ridiculous if you ever
watch the og episode go [ __ ] watch it
and you know what i watched the other
day i checked out i looked at the goblin
episode to see how i was doing
it's four hours and 20 minutes long
yep that episode is so [ __ ] long it's
the longest episode of all time yeah
i can't believe we sat there for almost
[ __ ] four and a half i don't think
people believe that that coincidentally
it was four hours and 20 minutes i
didn't realize it happened until i was
it was exported that that was the length
of this not on purpose guys like the 40
gram joint
video it's 40 minutes and 20 seconds
long it's just the gods
did not know that
i didn't know that was gonna happen
um
so this episode has been fun it's a good
one uh we got a lot of guests coming up
all right a lot of guests so we just
wanted to be here i was trying to force
this on you so i can [ __ ] give you
that
like you know what cause i told him like
yo i gotta give it to him on the podcast
why so it could be filmed and i can have
his face i'm so glad man you want to
talk about the last thing i [ __ ]
expected
i'm about to become an expert on this
shot yo you really should uh i'll tell
you after but one of my homies is
going all in
hard
but he already made so much money in
like four weeks i'm like yo what did you
just say you bought it for what you know
when we were talking about watches i'm
like i got it for this i sold it for 36
and i got it for 15. it feels like mr
wormwood from matilda danny when he's
naming off all the i bought this dodge
and i sold him sucker for 28 hundred
dollars that's how i feel like you got
that much money off of the watch in a
week
so first everybody out there invest your
money i'm not saying go buy watches
go invest your money into other things
start a business start a business that
you can start small and grow and expand
that's what we're all about here right
giving advice to people that the things
we [ __ ] up on
that's that's what we're here to do so
that's pretty much all we talk about
it's like don't [ __ ] up man everyone i
[ __ ] up
so we're just like it's okay this is how
what's supposed to be happening at this
point
you're supposed to feel like you're
gonna die and you're supposed to feel
like you can't do anything you're gonna
[ __ ] bang your head against the wall
and like yo if somebody shot me in the
head i probably wouldn't be pissed right
now
i've gotten to that broke tour i'm like
yo what do i do
i can't sell packs i'm not i can't do it
i'm gonna go to [ __ ] prison like it
was always that like i'm on the radar so
heavy i can't sell bags anymore
once you're the kid on the internet it's
over
evidence hey bring up his ig
evidence a
like what am i gonna do it's over
i'm [ __ ] so that's why so yeah for
everyone out there
it's okay it's gonna get better
all right
marty
got anything else to say
i love these episodes
it's revitalizing
and yeah we got a bunch of big guests
i'm just i'm i'm really
it's been it's been a [ __ ] week and
i'm just really excited to get back into
this
things are going really great we really
appreciate the support on all the videos
i'm
really excited to crank out these next
all this [ __ ] we got going on and just
keep smashing [ __ ]
motivation mondays all right brought to
you by
the dope as usual podcast all right and
today
miller lighting and joints
oh you got those great i was about to
talk that was amazing the kids
yeah we're all over 21 here okay i
promise even though you just heard some
kids
we're all over 21 here and for everyone
driving
thank you for being here and for
everyone on camera
i i mean i just realized when i went to
the bathroom went and did my hair i went
oh my whole shirt's ripped so i have a
big ass hole on this shirt i was like
we're about to start filming
so if anybody sees like yeah i know my
shirt's ripped guys you don't get a
comment we're at a shirt factory it's
[ __ ] fine
i wore that one last episode that's the
only
push trees all my stuff comes next week
so i only have one design left i'm out
of stuff and i wore it last week i don't
want to keep wearing it
so that's what i'm like i'll wear the
rip shirt just keep my arms down a
little bit just flexing the [ __ ]
upset
yeah no but i'm trying to keep my arm
down a little bit guys thank you uh i
could have said that to you off camera
completely but that's what we do here
all right
thank you guys so much for watching this
has been super fun i have no [ __ ]
idea what we're going to call this
but we'll come up with something
something less explicit thanks you
youtube for being nice to us thank you
guys for watching us here on youtube for
listening spotify apple podcast wherever
you listen to if you haven't already
please leave a
[ __ ] like if you're on spotify
i think you can heart episodes whatever
you can do to help us get a better
algorithm and get more fooled and the
biggest thing we always say
tell a friend
just tell one person to watch
and if they're your friend and you watch
they're probably gonna be a like-minded
person like you and probably like our
[ __ ] but if they're super offended easy
don't even try creeping up on 200k on
that youtube
it's gonna oh yeah oh yeah we're at like
160 something every every new number we
hit it becomes easier and easier to book
guests
that's a big thing too because you got
to remember yo you guys should give [ __ ]
a stoop dog and bob like yeah me too i
would love that also snoop dogg's like
warehouse where at who who how much you
paying yeah i think nothing
all right all right yeah i'll hit you
for four years it takes so much to give
people like i'm gonna say it's new dog
exactly we're saying like he's a [ __ ]
huge guest superstar that'd be the
biggest hardest that's one of the top
four goods of all time
thank you thank you that's one of the
hardest rules to get to come to your
podcast so
if we could that'd be epic but if we had
a [ __ ] million and when they looked
at it and go oh there's a million on
their [ __ ] okay so they're doing [ __ ]
people don't think that people always
think of numbers and it's always their
management they're like oh we're not
going to put snoop dogg
the most famous week i have all [ __ ]
time
on your little tiny pot that's how they
think i'm not saying like once again i'm
not saying them or anybody but that's
how i assume people think
because i mean
mario says ah
i remember that he's like every time
[ __ ] are like nah [ __ ] you
we're good
yeah okay cool cool
[Music]
yep no dude cool no that [ __ ] my
strings yeah all right we're good thank
you though have a good day uh-huh oh
you're too busy no that's good great
don't swear let's listen don't stress
about it we're all good yeah don't even
there's guys about a [ __ ] we're all
good
at it
yeah and we're not saying we're salty
and [ __ ] we're just saying like
it's fine
but we're just
we're fans i'm just letting you know
we have a really nice audience and they
would love to have you
i get it i get it some people like now
bro i am a superstar i can't be on a
little i get it i [ __ ] understand
like yo paul rudd come to our show like
i love paul rudd but i don't expect paul
rudd to go yeah i'll go to your pod
headache show uh-huh
you know what i mean but if you saw like
seven milligo
oh [ __ ] these fools are getting how many
views and that all right hot ones we'll
go on the hot ones yeah yeah that's how
it is
that's how it looks like fools are
eating hot wings yeah snot running yeah
it goes from [ __ ] you no i'm not coming
on your show with this
my new movie's colored out also hot ones
i would go on your show but that would
not last
vegan wings yeah i would not last
um but yeah that's that's how helps out
tell a friend that's
that took eight minutes for us to go hey
just tell a friend by the way
again eight minutes later and this is
why that's okay this is why it's an hour
and fifty instead of hour 30 because
we're at 151 mm-hmm right yeah are we
really yeah i'm [ __ ] on it twice
today [ __ ] bowling
guys thank you so much
that's right i was signing off
at 43 000 it literally wasn't eight
minutes yeah it's like a slow decent
coming into yeah we're [ __ ] truck
we're going in the [ __ ] low gear
we're downshifting our way out of here
i might as well just sleep here i have
to be back so [ __ ] early
but the set's gonna be worth it i'm
[ __ ] excited
guys thank you so much for being here
thank you everyone for making everything
possible [ __ ] stoked everything's
working out really good
um thank you guys for everyone out here
that's been here if you're in the chat
right now thank you [ __ ] appreciate
you
and that's it it's been a solo episode
we have a lot more guests coming up so
get ready we'll see you guys on the next
solo episode alright
this has been
marty o'neal drastic graphics thank you
guys i am thomas dobaziola this has been
the dope as usual podcast we have talked
about life problems drugs
accomplishments and a whole lot of in
between today thank you guys so much for
watching drive safe have a dope as day
i'm [ __ ] high man
i was like i didn't stutter [ __ ] my [ __ ]
i as i got through the words i was like
oh it's like when you catch a ball
you're like oh i caught it that's how i
felt right now
i can't believe it stutter right now
three joints
[Music]
perfect